see your right hand is trying to stop
him right do you see
that stopping
stopping
So eventually he's going to get through
like
that so as I
said if if I have to stop him and he
wants to come
forward so rather than stop him is as
he's pushing that angle you take him to
the
Tilt not here but take it into the tilt
just an easy one is just take it into a
tilt you can do different things with
his hand you see so he's in a tilt he'll
respond to it into the other
tilt you pushes
tilt pushes
tilt pushes tilt
not here eventually he's going to get
me he pushes tilts
tilt so if you look at this hand I came
around this way he went around the
outside and then I just stayed on the
inside but the difference was that as he
did that this hand I brought into the
Tilt do you see and then I can use this
hand
now
so again he was
pushing so I just pushed that hand there
this hand attempted to counter I stay on
the inside out it
goes so if you look he push I just went
and took it in but it's kind of stuck do
you feel it it's kind of stuck are you
pushing push it gets
stuck on the other one right I'm trying
to take take it he goes around the
outside I don't care I'll figure it out
it doesn't matter if you change it okay
so this time he went around this way I'd
come around this
way
pushing I'm on the
inside so I came this way he went around
the outside I stayed on the inside okay
do you feel the same
friction so again but not here so let's
look at it he is coming around I'm here
so let's look at that little circle
there's my heeld but it's taking him
into that tilt do you see and once you
have one part of the Tilt here's where
the C on the x pattern
works now imagine I did that same one I
I'll figure it I don't know if I'm doing
the same thing here but I don't do this
hand into the tail I don't yield on this
I hold him up and he's trying to go
around this hand you're trying to go
around this hand you're pushing on this
hand I'm holding you there look he goes
around this hand it won't be the same
thing you see that it will not be the
same thing it's this part that made it
work okay so again as he goes I don't
push I don't stop him where does he want
to go I can feel him you see I can feel
him go that way so I let him go that way
it's letting him go that
way
I don't know why you put yourself in a
wrist Lo but
okay no tilt you see same thing
tilt okay so you got to get that tilt
can't be S sitting up right heats up
right you're kind of just moving his
arms around okay try it
again
why do you think he's floating like that
because I'm holding him up S what
because I'm holding him up all right
let's
see he look he looks heavy there yes
okay so you you use the phrase you're
holding him
up and he looks heavy what would you say
he's happening are you pushing on him
yes yeah you're pushing on him do you
see he want wants to fall but you want
him to fall another
way okay that hence you're pushing on
him so you got to lose the way you want
him to fall you don't want a way have no
way
can't give up your Center Line
though you're pushing his chest you're
you're not doing some zombie thing
you're
doing you and you can push one hand both
hands you don't have to always push both
hands and we we don't want to move in
this drill okay that why that way it
emphasizes the tabaki otherwise we'd be
standing up you can use foot Maneuvers
all all day long
okay all right so Andrew I would say
what's happening is is you have an
external yield but you have to be your
yield remember has to be in the center
do you feel that you see I'm not going
he push his anle like that not just
getting out of the way I immediately
touch his Center so when he
counters he can keep touching his Center
okay so touch his Center then it'll
work just here won't work cuz he starts
leaning on you which is what you want
because that makes his Center but if
you're external he's leaning on you is
actually going to push push on you
external okay but you do want because
what the UK does is they feel that and
then he starts using me for balence and
that's good cuz you can just stop you
see that that's what I mean right I
don't I don't my goal is not to
overpower him so I wouldn't want to push
him out of his
fall so when he's totally leaning on you
he's falling you just take away the
handrail and they'll fall
okay so same thing there's the push
there's the center
always in the center you see that never
out on his arms never out on his arms
and then I pull the arm and eventually
the shoulder and then eventually the
center that's not it always in the
center always
in the
center okay let's try it
again do try to do that one again I want
you to show what I want to talk about
what's happening so get the elbow okay
now you feel his center right do you
okay we push to it okay there you go and
now what you do is you've picked the
angle and the throw that you want right
do you get that but he's kind of leaning
forward do you see that and as he
resists and tries to keep his balance go
ahead that's when you just outow him do
you understand that but why are we outp
powering what did I say you were
doing I don't know you had you had the
you already had the throw planned you
already see the throw in your head do
you see that and so now you're trying to
force it but the situation has changed I
show you what I
mean we'll come on this side so I do the
same side that you all right I don't
know what you're doing on this hand but
you had this hand here you see and
you're like there it is but he's pushing
on it you see that and so as you're
pushing on it that's that's our Center
connection do you understand that's your
young energy and so I could I could take
it this way all you see that
right so you had to throw there there it
is but he pushed into it that now it
goes this
way so I you you guys watch like how
seamless effortless it is you won't even
know that he tried to do that okay but
once I feel a thisy this guy pushed into
my Center then we just and it's easy
easy okay but now answer me what
actually made it difficult and what
actually made it
easy uh being stuck on one vector and
one pattern that's what makes it
difficult and what makes it easy uh not
not being so releasing yourself okay so
I as you're going and you feel it oh
there do you see and they like back I'll
get you back you see that but anyone
that's pushing into you what energy is
that so you turn
it and then easy peasy okay pushing back
on Yang is y Yang class very difficult
to do unless you're bigger than that
person but it's not iido it's not
Jiu-Jitsu okay so you have to bring this
to that spirit level where you'll feel
the desire and you have to release it
and instead keep the relationship ship
okay so go back to that technique so you
get what I'm talking about so as we're
going this part feels good what let's do
the one you did with h Gabriel do you
see that okay so watch watch watch and
you go slow so you can see you push that
part felt good to you you see that and
now it's starting to feel like [\h__\h]
right do you see that so instead as this
part feels good to you keep the good
feeling do you understand hey good
feeling is what are you feeling you're
feeling for that uh reconciliation of
Yin and okay all right try it
again don't hold
them don't hold
them
all
right so remember if you if you hold me
up then I'm going to not fall into any
void does that make sense you're you're
like I'm trying to touch your chest and
you don't want me to touch your chest
you're holding I can't go any more
forward you're bigger and stronger than
me I can't go forward you see so I'm not
in any
tilt
then you could have someone I guess
who's like driving and you get out of
the way do you see then I fall into it I
guess okay but it's probably not going
to be Tristan okay um so that's where
that adhesion is going to come in okay
because I need the friction I need the
the the stuckness okay so as you're
trying to touch me uh I am sticky do you
see sticky and so uh I with the
stickiness then the person who's maybe
I'm holding up do you see or the person
who's not going to give that much
opening I can get just an inch do you
see and this is l literally a game of
inches so if I push I'll be over young
and I won't be sticky except at the
right angles so as soon as he try you
try to get off of that right angle you
see I I you felt that little slip there
okay uh and then what happened we'll do
that one again so on the right angle of
course I'm stuck but once you get off
the right angle look where I ended up do
you see and that was what was happening
a lot to you okay and remember in this
game because I want to understand the
Kon waza tabaki I want to float around
the wrist and the and the Hand range I
don't want to come up to the elbows for
other Ledges okay so I'm I'm stuck and I
wait and I just match I match what
you're doing you see and you can feel
like it's almost like there's tentacles
on me because as you're rolling around I
feel different parts sticking so right
here it's there on that thumb here it's
in the palm and as you move right it's
over here now on the pinky finger do you
see and it's up higher here on the
knuckles so I'm feeling that kind of
stuff and but I every time you move I'm
letting it go you see letting it go but
I I getting the sticky part so there's a
little tilt I get you to respond to it
by pushing a little okay there we go
right and but you can feel the friction
again you feel it like that man that
that's a stuck hand okay then you'll do
do something to get off of that there we
go and there we
are so don't over young which will
always happen when you try to stop him
especially with right angles so don't
seek your right angles seek the
stickiness sticky you can feel how she
just gets like velcro a little bit okay
so release you feel it stuck again
stuck stuck again it even went
okay and that's by not over Ying you
matching your y mat there it is right
there match you can feel our skins
moving okay that's what for from
matching your y
Okay match match
match so you're moving your hand around
but you can see I'm just sticking to it
okay it's not it's
impossible for you to move your hand
around like move your hand around in a
circle and for me to stay up with it but
if I'm stuck to it you feel it again the
skin gets moved and as you move then not
you're just moving
me me trying to stay up with it is not
going to have the same thing on the arms
for me to see what your arms are not
going to work but if I'm stuck there it
is that skin again if I'm stuck to it
then I can stay with you so as you try
to get off of it I feel the stickiness
happening
you get it so I work more by feel by
feeling and not by sight okay and I'm
just matching that Feelgood feeling see
that harmonization of Yin and Yang
that's where the communion happens
that's the I key there um and again
there's a lot of you know a lot of
people are you're just supposed to feel
it yeah yeah you are supposed to feel it
because you can't see it you can't see
it even he can't see it but he can feel
his skin being moved you see as we're
stuck there so you can feel the adhesion
uh that's why I use that word and and
have you look for it because you can
feel it but you can't see it okay so you
have to be fine with the teacher telling
do you feel it yeah I [\h__\h] feel it
yeah I feel it okay and now you have to
chase the feeling not chasing what
you're seeing okay
right
so do you feel the pushing or is it or
do you hide it from yourself no no I
okay
right
there right
there right there right
there
there there
so remember there's three elements or
aspects to your being you have your
physical
being and you have your energetic being
and then you have your
spiritual aspect your spiritual being
okay and in AO you train in all three of
them you can't train in
one so you have
something in the Zen tradition called
Coons and sometimes it's translated as
riddle but that's not a good a good uh
term for it it's not a
riddle it's not like what's green and
red and it's going 100 miles per hour
frog in a blender it's not that
okay they're really like like um chokes
or igniters or catalysts for the egoic
mind so you would do all your Zen
training and you would
uh practice your meditation do your
cleaning uh do all your rituals Etc you
would do your
servitude uh you place yourself into the
social hierarchy you take on that cohi
role and you would work on cultiva
humility and releasing of the self Etc
and then eventually you're going to go
in and the Abbot is going to give you a
[\h__\h] and what it is is it's it's
something that the Abbot knows will
spark your ego tripartite
mind and the Abbot knows in their
experience how to
read the functioning of the ego
tripartite mind
okay so the Abbot would give you one of
these things that triggers your ego
tripartite mind because Virginia you
know the hand of two hand clappings
what's the hand of what's the sound of
one hand clapping you know the sound of
two hands what's the sound of one hand
what is it what is
it so the
nodding the affirmation there's no
affirmation to that thing and the I
don't know there's nothing to know
do you see but the
conversation the word selection the body
language the proxic all that stuff is
going to be a catalyst for the
functioning of the ego tripartite mind
and then the master goes not enough you
saying you go back to your practices
okay in
iido we don't use the [\h__\h] we use the
push
the push is going to be that same spark
that same Catalyst that will trigger
your ego tripartite
mind how will you trigger the master is
going to know how how what that looks
like so what do you think it looks
like what do you think how is how does
it manifest itself say it loud enough go
for it what tension in the body right
nonacceptance do you see that
that uh if I have not acceptance then I
have preference do you see so I have
desire I have
want I have something I'm trying to
avoid and something I'm trying to have
and what does that look like what does
that look like cuz that was your
thing um pushing back on yeah like
you're pushing you're young young
clashing do you do you get that um what
how else does it
manifest what other signs of tension non
acceptance y y clashing will you see in
the
dasi holding breath holding breath right
right all tense and stuff jaw clenching
uh face flexing all of those things
right the movement is not relaxed and
effortless right uh what else about the
movement what will the movement do do
you think it's going to look like
this
if I'm in the god mine am I going to
look like this short
choppy geometric movement no it's going
to be flowing and circular and spiral do
do you understand right what's going to
happen to my Bas of
support it's going to go up right I hold
my breath I put tension in my and I
start to rise up as my glutes and my
legs start to flex because because of
the fear response right all that stuff
has to happen do you guys get it okay so
in a way as you're going here this is
your Co your
[\h__\h] and we don't want to see that do
you see we want to see the godm state
happening
you feel my hands you kind look at my
hands look how
relaxing
[Music]
okay do you understand so that's your
[\h__\h] training that's what that's what
we're doing but it's energetically it's
not intellectually your the functioning
of your intellect is the functioning of
your egoic mind but YY clashing energy
that's also the functioning of your
egoic mind
okay